you mentioned in a prior interview that
you on must is one of your idols
testimonies face XP anything that you
were sort of noticing about the way he's
done things that you're both taking in
just various theories er well I mean one
thing that you'll unless it does that's
really great is that he puts his money
where his mouth is he really believes in
his projects and he puts himself out
there as the you know public front for
those projects he's not hiding behind
other companies you know with one foot
in one foot out hoping that it will
succeed he really goes out there and and
pushes and uses his past history and
uses his public image to get people on
board and get people excited he also
just he takes the long view and I think
that's something that were very much
trying to do also he he doesn't he's not
thinking about what his market will be
this year next year even in the next
five years he's really understanding the
marketplace over the next 10 20 30 50
years and when you hear him talk about
SpaceX and other things like that he's
talking about fifty years down the road
and and that's very much what we are
also trying hard to do is make a product
that won't be outdated next year or two
years from now but that something like a
film school could still be using our
cameras 10 years from now and still it
would be a viable product in the market
because that's why we're so adamant on
it a raw only camera because I think in
five years when you look back all these
compression formats and things like that
will seem like part of the old school
being part of the history and raw will
be what part of the future we want to be
part of what is to come
think that this might sound a little
cheesy but you know he's finding
problems that exist with the way that
you know we have space travel now or
with paypal how you know money was being
exchanged and he saw these problems and
wanted to fix them and really wanted to
push the ability of the average person
to a level that other
sometimes we have a really large company
even to make minor details are changed
in your product can be very very
difficult requires a lot of overhead a
lot of meetings and it it can be very
difficult to push your technology
forward at that level but he's someone
has come in and said you know what
electric cars really need to be the
forefront of where we are you know for
climate reasons for other reasons you
know this is really where we need to be
and nobody else interested in pursuing
this so I'm going to pursue it and I
think a lot of you know what we wanted
to do as filmmakers making a camera for
other filmmakers was going to pulled
that into the equation and this was
something that you know we felt was not
being added to the market that we think
should be available to everybody and
that's why we're pushing to created
you